familienalltag heute mehr als 20 jahre
sind vergangen seit die
chancengleichheit für frauen und männer
gesetzlich eingeführt wurde
wo stehen wir heute und welche
familienmodelle werden gelebt
[Musik]
ganz gleich welches modell man wählt für
berufstätige mütter stellt sich die
frage wie bringt man alles unter einen
hut
[Musik]
kathrins familienmodellen ist heute das
häufigste in der schweiz
sie arbeitet teilzeit ihr mann voll
mehr als die hälfte aller familien leben
so ihr mann rafael ist seit drei jahren
sp stadtrat und vorsteher des zürcher
sozialdepartements als die kinder kamen
war das familienmodell noch nicht
definiert ich mache was ich einfach
fotografiert prozent reduzierten konto
unserer ob dann auch noch ein und
standen aber das hätte eigentlich gern
gemacht
dann kam der große karrieresprung
du darfst das einzige politik keine
klagen kann das politische ist immer das
thema xiii und dann die möglichkeit
statt sich eröffnet haben
die klage soll ich schöner park &
bellheimer ist an die gerichte der
eigentlich heute arbeitet er mehr als
100 prozent
oft in den abend hinein ein termin reiht
sich an den anderen
ausnahmsweise kürzt raphael auch mal
eine sitzung ab um seine kinder zu sehen
das auch als dass das frieren xi ist das
verständnis ist er da
ich habe jetzt hatte ich später doch
manu klindworth in winzige oder krippe
bringen oder ich danke für ihren körper
oder auch bekommt mit drin zu bringen
für die familienarbeit ist kathrin
zuständig weil sie weiterarbeiten wollte
war von anfang an klar dass sie ihre
kinder in die krippe bringt und die
machen ja viele sachen ich nicht
wirklich machen besonders bei mir immer
besetzt
die möglichkeit kontakt zu anderen
halten
ja ich glaube dass ich in brünn und ich
sind sie sind nicht sozialisiert dass es
die länder alleine teilen und
miteinander auskommen
ich habe
[Musik]
die klassische doppelbelastung der
modernen frau spätestens um 9 will die
juristin am zürcher obergericht sein
dort hat sie einen 50 prozent
bei barbara in winterthur beginnt jeder
tag anders
sie und ihr mann teilen sich familien
und berufsarbeit gleichmäßig auf am
dienstag hat barbara morgen dienst es
ist einfach extrem abwechslungsreich ja
und ich merkte schon wenn es dann wieder
einen tag der heimat mit den kindern
dann freue ich mich auch wieder aufs
büro und und andersrum als ich finde
jetzt eigentlich perfekte situation dass
man von von allem was hat als heute
gehen alle am mittag in hort und haben
alle am nachmittag noch unterricht und
dann geht er wieder in hort und dann
holt euch der papa ab weiter arbeiten 80
prozent in kaderpositionen jeder bleibt
einen tag zu hause
die restlichen drei tage sind die kinder
im hort am besten ist natürlich wenn
immer alles gleich läuft aber das tut
sie ja nett und sobald sich irgendwie
kleinigkeit ändert dann dann gibt es
wieder ein riesen organisationsaufwand
dass es glaubt einfach das schwierigste
das beide einfach nimmer flexibel sind
also besonders wenn dann wenn dann zum
beispiel der kind krank wird dann ist
natürlich wer bringt jetzt wär wär
gädheim früher von der arbeit wer hat
keinen termin wer hat das letzte mal
gemacht so das sind dann immer die
diskussionen nur gerade eines von 20
paaren in der schweiz hat sich so
organisiert dieses familienmodell ist
immer noch die ausnahme
barbaras mann mike arbeitet bei der axa
winterthur im oberen kader
die firma unterstützt vereinbarkeit
modelle
doch im umfeld hat es schon fragen
gegeben
die htc das ist authentisch ganz okay
weil dafür brennt mit meiner familie
gemacht und das eigentlich gemacht dass
gerade nicht
für die anderen ist vielleicht der frau
korruption der zoff zwischen den
spielern finanzielle frage ich habe
dieses modell muss halt sehr gut
funktioniert und bei die auf das
zweithäufigste modell ist nach wie vor
dass frauen ihre berufstätigkeit bei der
geburt der kinder ganz aufgeben
daniela lebt in bassersdorf und ist
vollzeit mami von zwei schulpflichtigen
töchtern eine von fünf müttern in der
schweiz macht es so du hast geschaffen
ich wohne wie der haushalte haben sie
nach einem bestritt für mich familie war
nicht familie dass sie es im job muss
mit einer familie mit
danielas mann patrick arbeitet 100 als
it spezialist bei der migros im gange
dass sie natürlich extrem dünn aber die
mutigen stinka hatten aber noch vom
traditionellen montag ursprünglich und
und für uns hat er sei die post das ist
nicht so aussieht dass sie mich ein
bisschen überredet dass ich jetzt mit
der hingucker schafft und haben das
diskutiert und das hat für beide posten
darum ist das ein relativ schnell zwar
als sie mir das noch an jene infrage
gestellt wie es funktioniert und ich
finde es möglich sich forscher die
unfair gegenüber dem trend zur hat ob er
dann nicht für sie da ist
also wir haben ganz bewusst sein die
wand das klingt auch mit teldafax und wo
fremdplatziert sind für barbara wäre
dieses traditionelle modell nicht in
frage gekommen bevor sie arbeiten geht
bringt sie die kinder zum schulbus
es ist kurz nach den sommerferien alle
stundenpläne sind neu da passiert es
schon mal dass doch nicht alles läuft
wie am schnürchen
wir haben zwei mal verschwunden
aber ich glaube das war nicht so
tragisch oder und am freitag und am
freitag hat es noch ein kleines
missverständnis gegeben
da ist er da dachten wir der vincent
geht in hort und er geht freitags ins
schwimmen und wenn er ins schwimmen geht
wird er zum zu seinem kollegen mit
heimgehen und jetzt war aber die woche
noch gar kein schwimmen aber er ist
trotzdem mit zum kollegen und der mic
wollte ihn abholen vom hort und dann war
er nicht da das war der pc eine
chaotische an dem tag
naja du kannst nichts dafür tut ihr
gleich einsteigen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ehemann mike ist schon seit sieben im
büro
dafür muss er am nachmittag die kinder
abholen teilzeit und home office sind
hier problemlos möglich
jeder versteht das thema leben
geschaffen wird jetzt ohne krone 30 hier
also muss es nicht thematisiert er wo
sich die exotische das ist normal im
teamhotel sie die axa bekommt regelmäßig
preise für ihre vereinbarkeit bemühungen
verantwortlich für die umsetzung der
diversity strategie ist yvonne sei sie
ist selbst zweifache mutter und arbeitet
70 prozent auch sie teilt die
familienarbeit mit ihrem mann einzieht
und die flexible arbeitsmodelle sind
frauen wichtig finde frau monika
abmahnen und immer meine ich glaube wenn
man will wiederholt ihre ganze thematik
verführbarkeit verpuffung familie
verglich stelle überhaupt denn lange
zeit wenn man sich nur auf frauen
fokussiert sondern sich extrem wichtig
dass man auf optimale sorgt wo sind die
bedürfnisse und das modell in teilzeit
oder flexible arbeitsmodelle generell
eben nicht nur für frauen und männer
parat steht für männer hier ist es kein
karrierekiller mehr wenn sie teilzeit
arbeiten aktuell ich denke wirklich
darüber nach auf 80 prozent
runterzugehen momentan der kleine ist
vier jahre alt und am funktioniert ganz
gut meine frau ist 80 prozent arbeiten
ich 100 und wir sind mit vielen freunden
außenrum gut organisiert also momentan
geht es noch mal schauen also es kann
gut sein dass ich auf 80 runter kleines
teils auf 1% und grund ist primär dass
sie mehr zeit für mich selber h und zum
beispiel cargo reise oder hobby ist kein
auto wir haben schon sehr bewusst über
leid wie wieder untersagt arbeitgeber
ist jetzt aber auch so dass in diesem
umfeld das sehr viel gemacht hat und die
jetzt doch nicht in his black sea wo
haben ist sondern hat keine profitieren
auch von anderen
oder schon umgesetzt der anteil teilzeit
arbeitende männer ist um 50 prozent
gestiegen
seit flexible modelle gefördert werden
es ist ein kulturwandel früher normale
jahr für sachen modells sie das thema
erwerbstätig ist schon frau ist für
kinder sehr als erfolgsmodell
und ich finde jeder selber entscheiden
will das modell stimmt aber ich glaube
zwischen wandel in gang das junge männer
wofür die unis römerhalle gleichen
ausbildungsstand sind wie frauen
freundinnen und das mit inhalt der filme
über leid für zehn wurf und familie
kombinieren wir immer das machen aber
ich glaube es braucht die kultur und die
sichtbarkeit dass es okay ist umso
modell leben an die kiel hat als top
banker früher 300000 franken im jahr
verdient als sein sohn auf die welt kam
ist er aus dem hamsterrad ausgestiegen
um 100% hausmann zu sein also mit
smartcard und zwar wäre extrem
beansprucht city und das mit abstand
strengen stieg sie wurden jemals gemacht
hat und auf der anderen seite hat die
gesellschaftlichen felix leisten könne
sie im unternehmen sie das ist mir
extrem wichtig und darum wie schade für
mich leider stehen oder film ist für
meine person ein teilzeitpensum seht ihr
alle war nicht abwurf und familien
hinterland machen
seither versucht er dieses modell auch
für männer in chefetagen salonfähig zu
machen
bekannt durch das buch der teilzeit man
hat er mit seinem startup teilzeit
karriere einer internetplattform für
solche jobs geschaffen
wenn es geht arbeitet er im impact habe
dem ersten coworking space in zürich
hier arbeiten frauen und männer ohne
fixe arbeitszeiten an ihren projekten
selbstständige und kaderleute
nebeneinander die geschlechterfrage
spielt im alltag hier keine rolle mehr
und auf der anderen die polarität vor
der foto geschlechter oder oder mehr
männer kämpfen am ende recht um mehr
frauen für sie frau bericht ist indes
komplett überholt auch wenn man in der
gleichstellung ein stück weit gekommen
ist teilzeit carter jobs gibt es bisher
nur wenige jetzt aber mit zunehmendem
fachkräftemangel beginnt sich das zu
ändern
leitende ärzte 50 prozent das sind
genauso modellreihe
da ist genau und klassiker gibt es ein
fachkräftemangel oder zu wenig ärzte
geriatrie sowieso erstmal und ernst
wurde schlimm ist es in den dingen
heranmacht detail sieht inserate mehr
empfehlen diesen maßnahmenkatalog dass
man alle still 80 bis 100 prozent
schrieb und das machen aber immer mehr
unternehmen als genuss der größere
signal wirklichkeit und will es interne
großes signal haid wärmeren job gegen
externe times schrieb das heißt dass man
intern der job nach den acht prozent
chance für verschiedene unternehmen
unter anderem die spd die post die
zürich und swisscom schreiben
kaderstellen neu auch teilzeit aus doch
meistens sind teilzeit jobs keine kader
jobs katrin arbeitet als
gerichtsschreiberin am obergericht und
hat wie die meisten mütter ihr pensum
herunter gefahren nachdem die kinder auf
die welt gekommen sind und dass sich 50
verteilt was noch praktische weniger
stressen gerade das beste für ihre
politische karriere als sp kantonsrätin
hat sie aufgegeben
ich hatte es hat mir sage ich auch die
sache und es ist also ihr kind die halle
zu gehen
der job com ist nicht wichtig ist und
iranpolitik kann dann ist gleich drei
erfolgs und alles miteinander
einfach täglich an ihren könne seriös
machen
begriff am obergericht hat sich viel
verändert in den letzten 20 jahren
früher eine männerdomäne arbeiten hier
heute mehrheitlich frauen
es gibt teilzeitstellen und flexibler
arbeitsmodelle sind möglich die hand
ganz rechts platz 8 prozent weiblichen
mitarbeitern die mannes in der
minderheit und das ist es eben bilder
von der universität gerade im news
bereich der uni zürich sind sechs
prozent studenten über abschließend und
das wird dann am pos abzeichnen bei den
richtern ist das verhältnis allerdings
immer noch umgekehrt
grund die meisten richter stellen sind
100 prozent stellen und von männern
besetzt
mein blick gar nicht rind zweite gitarre
teilzeitpensen und im moment ist es aber
nicht so vordringlich könnte mir
vorstellen will ich finde ich hat wenig
spaß weil man als großer stress will hat
ja so viele saudi habe mir liegt und das
erledigt sich an einfach so von
geisterhand
aber das ist schon immer mit zählt sehnt
man sich wenn man noch niedrig wichtig
für den moment ist ihr einen fuß im job
zu behalten ihren karrierewunsch hat
katrin wie viele andere mütter auf
später verschoben
der kinder wegen als juristin sind ihr
die finanzielle nachteile ihres modells
aber durchaus bewusst das problem
schwierig wird es dann wenn die
beziehung dann habe ich natürlich
weniger erfahrung und kann vor wiese
ich will natürlich dann nur noch wenige
pensionskassen haben dann natürlich
geringer wäre wenn ich meinen sie
könnten ja es gibt schon auch von der
modellplanung meistens vertrauen
[Musik]
daniela genießt es dass sie sich ihre
zeit frei einteilen kann wenn die
mädchen in der schule sind dass sie kein
eigenes geld mehr verdient daran musste
sich die ehemalige bank fachfrau aber
erst gewöhnen kann ich das könne
entscheide ich mir das leisten
und ja dann natürlich quasi das parfüm
kaufen oder leisten
ja wir haben es den mittag lag das minus
im sondern in kleinen betrag sagt geld
überwiesen bekommt obwohl ich dann auch
für ihn kann das als junkie auf den
geburtstag an gepusht und muss ihnen
sagen durch 50 oder 100 frank h
dass ich ein bisschen missbraucht
[Musik]
sie setzt alle energie für ihre familie
ein
was würde es bedeuten wenn diese
plötzlich auseinanderbreche immerhin
werden in der schweiz 40 prozent der
ehen geschieden wusste ich aber dass er
sich für kind ohne probleme beruf und
ich denke mir dann müssen wir sowieso um
danke dann wäre ich ja in der pflicht
zum mittleren teil gut geschaffen und
auch mittragen
das ist mir bewusst ja wieder einsteigen
will sie noch nicht aber ab und zu
streckt sie die fühler aus farbige gebe
also keinen vorstellungsgespräch es hat
durchgehend insofern dass das mich
sowieso noch gewarnt und chips über die
usa ihr mann patrick könnte sich
durchaus vorstellen zu reduzieren
das soll sich in die küstenorte sind was
ich etwas abstand gewertet und das ist
auch schon thematisiert und dass man
dann jeder das gefühl hat sie willi sich
anders ich betätige dass sie sie konkret
zu irgendeiner prozentsatz dass sich
arminia arbeitszeit reduzieren
das anders organisieren das sind noch
keine konkrete planung aber ich glaube
die möglichkeiten sind da
die migros ist ein kooperativer
arbeitgeber vaterschaftsurlaub ist
bereits eingeführt und teilzeit wird
geschlechtsunabhängig auf allen stufen
gefördert bei der ubs so barbara
arbeitet gibt es kein solches
vereinbarkeit programm
aber sie hat glück gehabt
sie konnte mit einer 80 prozent
mutterschaftsvertretung im marketing
einsteigen
nachher wurden beide frauen sie und ihre
kollegin chantal mit fixen kader
verträgen angestellt und dann ist die
uci ist ein klassisch männliches prägte
betrieb barbaras chef ist holländer
er sieht frau und förderung pragmatisch
wir müssen flexibel sein und wir können
das organisieren aber sie müssen auch
flexibel sein
gestern zum beispiel hatten beide frei
aber wir hatten ein meeting und es war
dann so dass zumindest eine der beiden
für zwei stunden ins büro kommen konnte
die kinder in empfang nimmt und ich bin
dann etwas später wieder zurück gekommen
damit ich das meeting hier wahrnehmen
kann
aber das ist eben genau das was halt was
halt auch positiv ist
in der situation wo ich jetzt gegen das
zeigt dass ich versuchen flexibel zu
sein wenn's sein muss aber das auch
natürlich der arbeit die bei mir
entgegenkommen wenn ich dann mal
kurzfristig ausfallen also dass das
wirkliche leben und weniger aus barbaras
modell geht nur weil mike auch teilzeit
arbeitet und übernehmen kann wenn sie
spontan ins büro muss spezialist für
gleichstellungsfragen ist
unternehmensberater matthias müller
ob firmen moderne modelle fördern hängt
seiner meinung nach von verschiedenen
faktoren ab wo die sagen er endlich
passiert war es endlich gibt es mal
ideen was man da genau machen könnte und
es gibt andere da ist einfach wieder
stand die angst hat wieso das hat jetzt
unsere firma gibt es 100 jahre und es
hat immer so funktioniert wie so sei
aber dass jetzt plötzlich ändern
es hängt glaube ich davon ab wie stark
die unter druck stehe eine firma die sid
ich kriege keine fachkräfte mehr
oder auch wie die firma wurde jetzt
hingehen wo sind generationenwechsel in
der führung gibt da ist natürlich eine
andere motivation zur veränderung dar
bei ifolor hat der ehemalige swissair
personalchef ein beratungsmandat
follower muss mit der digitalen
entwicklung schritt halten wenn die
firma marktleader bleiben will
philipp schwarz will modernisiert um
gute fachleute zu kriegen sollen
teilzeit und home office auf allen
hierarchiestufen und geschlechter
unabhängig möglich sein
gibt es denn da noch irgendwie
widerstand oder was von der aus der
führungs ecke so gegen flexibles
arbeiten home office und solche
geschichten oder es kommt da sind alle
dafür da sind alle dafür
dann geht es dann haben wir es noch
haben personen die einträge für ihre
mini wenn wir feststellten dass mir noch
attraktiv im arbeitsmarkt für
mitarbeitende sind und denke so zwei
varianten entweder sie schließe den
laden oder sie passt sich der aktuelle
zieht und daher ist ganz klar für die
zweite weg entschieden ist der aktuelle
stand vor allem spezialisten werden von
den neuerungen profitieren
philipp schwarz ist aber auch aus
persönlicher erfahrung für flexible
arbeitsmodelle erstens mal ein
familienfilm margit lang fahrer haben
möchte
und jetzt eine familie gründeten und
naja er wird wieder vater und will sich
seine arbeitszeit nun freier einteilen
als bisher
barbara begrüßt die neue entwicklung auf
dem arbeitsmarkt aus erfahrung weiß sie
aber dass es doch ein gewisses minimal
pensum braucht wenn man karriere machen
will
egal ob als frau oder als man wenn man
auf 80 prozent reduziert so in dem dreh
ist glaub so vieles möglich irgendwie in
führungspositionen
aber das problem ist halt das dann
frauen häufig mehr reduzieren als 80%
ich glaube das ist dann schon das was
dann die falle irgendwo auch ist aber
also sicher sind wollen auch viele
frauen gar nicht mehr arbeiten also die
wollen wirklich dann auch gleich vier
tage weg vom kindsein aber inwieweit es
jetzt wirklich was frauen oder männer
spezifisches ist oder inwieweit halt
auch von der gesellschaft so
so normiert ist sozusagen das ist dann
natürlich die andere frage
immer donnerstags ist barbaras mann mike
zu hause los das machen wir doch martin
organe also weniger nachruhm aber nur
blumen ganzen tag daheim eine meldung
der neuen eigentlich und dort
historische mühle jetzt und kommt dort
würde man viel spaß
[Musik]
mit dem kind zusammen
jetzt ist das ganz ganz früher in der
bezirk entscheidet weil das modell und
wenn ich als rollenmodell du nach
das sind rund 20 völlig hilflos
wuchtigen wir ganz viel betreuung und
dass sie schicken wir als auch im
naturell joachim król und ein dieb der
situation ganz früh traf schon mal seit
bitte war übernimmt
dem kind dann richtet man sehr schnell
das ist ein total verliebt und morgen im
vergangen und die rollenverteilung
zwischen den geschlechtern ist
tatsächlich noch fest in den köpfen
verankert dass merz kathrin auch bei
sich selbst
meine frau und ich glaube ich würde mich
wetten dass ich beides referee bauen
dass ich das ich habe unter der woche
sieben verbringen mit animierten der
vater noch machen vielleicht auch
egoistisch dass ich ständig das
teilzeitmodell sowie es katrin lebt geht
für die meisten familien nur auf wenn es
genügend krippenplätze gibt
rafael ist als sozial vorstand der
oberste krippen chef der stadt zürich
pressekonferenz zu den finanzen er hat
gute nachrichten dialog aua maschinen
sind der entwicklung bietet ripper platz
mit subventionen also mit nlp
subventions berechtigt wer kann sollte
geschrieben platz und können zur
verfügung stelle wären die ziellinie in
der betreuung speed wurde cantona
abgeschafft hand warnte tripcke
finanzierung investiere zu mehr genau
der guide können schlimmste wo man im
bereich verändern betreuung hand zum
ersten mal gibt es damit in der stadt
zürich genügend subventionierter
krippenplätze wird dass die
rollenmodelle verändern 100 prozent
schafft eine neue studie belegt dass
eltern ihre kinder immer noch lieber
selber betreuen wenn es finanziell
möglich ist für daniela war die krippe
nie eine option wenn wir das geschlecht
die institution findet überhaupt nicht
aber es ist schon ein bisschen ethnofolk
wie sie dass ich nicht mehr schaffe und
zweitens ich kann wählen so wie man das
gemacht hat der heime sie und kin two
was sie mit ihnen zu mittag aß auch ein
apfelbaum monika klopfen sie in den
schuhen auf dem pausenplatz die
emotionale sache
als vollzeit mami ist sie für alles da
sie haben die sache muss sie selber
mitmachen
mit amtlichen mäßig aber wo man hat
angst dass das sie sagen dass auch
verantwortlich sind
danke die damals in verdacht immer
ungewiss und sie sind sich meine ich gar
nicht richtig bewusst wie schwierig
werden es auch nicht werden wir das
alles probiert hat für viele jüngere
frauen ist das keine alternative mehr
sie sind gut ausgebildet und kommen neu
auf den arbeitsmarkt
matthias mölle unterrichtet an der hwz
personal management und diversity in der
nächsten zeit wollen wir uns hier in dem
unterricht jetzt mal mit dem thema
gender diversity männer frauen
beschäftigen
ich glaube da haben wir noch
handlungsbedarf oder warum machen wir da
weiß worum es ist so wichtig für einfach
wir sagen einfach in männer werden
geschäfts- und die frau nicht oder
umgekehrt
wer einfach werde einfach oder
genau das wollte dass das hat sich
inzwischen wirklich herumgesprochen
gemischte teams sind erfolgreicher
personalverantwortliche verschiedener
firmen sollen lernen wie man mehr frauen
ins obere management bringt fakt ist
dass frauen im männerdominierten
unternehmen wenig aufstiegschancen haben
dass man sagt ihr müsst bei der auswahl
auf eine stelle
speziell führungsposition mindestens 30
keine bestimmten prozentsatz an
weiblichen bewerbern haben und da das
hat ihm den erfolg wenn ich merke dann
bewerben sie ja gar nicht 30 prozent
frauen in einem männerdominierten
unternehmen haben die frauen ja
irgendwie instinktiv das gefühl hier
komme ich ja nicht weiter und dann und
die die sich für führung interessieren
melden sich auch nicht weise unternehmen
und werden sich da auch nicht anmelden
für eine beförderung hatte keinen sinn
da sind die viel zu pragmatisch so aber
wenn ich will wenn ich zwingend ein
drittel meiner bewerber auf der liste
müssten frauen seien da muss ich
natürlich überlegen wie man sie den
charakter und die persönlichkeit meines
unternehmens meiner abteilung verändern
damit frauen das überhaupt attraktiv
finden
gerade in dienstleistungsunternehmen
steht dem nichts im wege
ich glaube sie sind in so einer
transition also nehm ich sehe jedenfalls
war vielleicht ist es falsch aber ich
nehme sie war in seinem übergang
wir sind mittendrin würde ich mal sagen
das hat sich bestimmt einiges bewegt
aber es gibt noch viel luft nach oben
also extrem viel luft und ich finde halt
in der schweiz auffiel das thema das ich
noch mehr spüren würde dass die frauen
auch noch mehr wollen also das einfach
diese klassische rollenteilung noch sehr
stark vertreten ist das muss halt
natürlich auch jeder mensch für sich
selber entscheiden aber wenn man
natürlich auch mehr männer hätten die
noch mehr teilzeit arbeiten würden die
sagen ich mache auch meinen part in der
familienarbeit und die frauen dann auch
wieder entlasten wärs beiden eine win
win situation und das sehe ich so als
langfristiges ziel gewalt gesellschaft
hin kommen könnten oder sollten wir
müssten mikes ältester sohn vincent hat
zum ersten mal training
geschäftliches lässt sich auch vom
fußballplatz aus erledigen
eigentlich hat barbara reik auf die idee
gebracht dass man sich auch so
organisieren könnte
ich glaube viele männer machen sie hat
überhaupt keine gedanken und proxy das
tier ja irgendwie dass die sachen wieder
impulse pro darüber nachdenken was sie
eigentlich wirklich wort ist ja auch
nicht so dass jetzt frau bevor das jetzt
als prozent soll schaffen sondern das
ist mir einfach ein wunsch prophetisch
kleid wurden und über das an die nachher
dankt uns ja em das jahr hat darüber
nachdenkt umso um uns umso mehr honig
fall eine woche vor dem gedanken
schussbereit ja ein wenig aufgewachsen
wie viel an etwa vom vortag an und
sicher völlig klassisches modell mini
ltv tat wahnsinnig scharf erzählte der
maxi und um so vielleicht ja eigentlich
mehr von ihnen hinter sonys dass das 2h
einfach dann bewusst eine reform weil
aber trotzdem hatte er nie die absicht
deswegen auf einer karriere zu
verzichten
ja so ausspruch anspruch an
herausfordernden job anspruch ein
spannender job anspruch das ganze diene
das ist ja ein ausspruch von lego und
meego vierzügigkeit hektar oben schossen
das gleichzeitige damit ästhetik familie
andy kiel hat ebenfalls einen weg
gefunden beides zu kombinieren
zehn tage im monat macht er home office
und betreut seinen sohn in altstätten wo
er aufgewachsen ist hat er sich zudem
ein zweites standbein geschaffen und
einen jugendtraum erfüllt er baut beton
badewannen und beton küche ein
lukratives geschäft im hochpreissegment
sein betonwerk führt ihr
selbstverständlich teilzeit und modern
dance prinzip dass alle alles gesehen
und alles fürs kind alles auflösen alle
abrechnung alles und das führt auch dazu
dass mehreren einheitliche lohnstruktur
buchen und der baskets guard mit dass
eine massiv mehr verdient oder oder
extra bürstädter oder oder so sagt und
das beinhaltet natürlich hatte sie ihren
lohn haben etiketten oder im betrieb an
die liebt konsequenz ein neues modell
beruflich und privat
für mich gab es nur miteinander familie
familie zu gründen oder finde ich finde
das ein wahnsinn dass er als maurer ist
erika moskau das mini 530 frauen mit
beglichen und billig nach mit kindheit
liebt und die vita karriere machen
sie findet es völlig irrwitzige
vorstellig und wie viel da also mehr
kräuter als wir nicht weniger männlich
wenn ihr welche waschmaschine selber
schildern hat er wenn ihre unterkunft
schlage härter und noch eine riesige
chance
ich finde dass menschlichkeit oder gegen
hannah behandeln wenn ihr genauso
gehören wie amazon pflaster draufkleben
für maicon barbaras kinder ist es auch
egal ob papa oder mama zu hause ist
hauptsache jemand ist da das
funktioniert aber nur mit regelmäßigem
agent jack und da kommt eine mutter oder
ein elternabend am 8
auch da sein da bist du nicht da aber
das kann ja deine mutter auch nicht okay
luc sturm mit bunt stückwerk bis zum opa
und durch
es ist die zweite woche wo man in sorge
wachsen und das ist erst mal schwimmen
und fußball und dennoch denn ist und
irgendwie und den stufenplan kennen wir
noch nicht so richtig als wir haben noch
nicht im kopf waren jetzt tun ist und
wann wann jemand im wald geht und das ja
das muss man alles noch am donnerstag um
5 an die zeit als paar haben sie im
moment praktisch nicht katrin hat
inzwischen allein von der krippe
abgeholt und eingekauft
vier spieler vater hat lucia aus dem
haus geholt und hilft am abend mit es
geht zu hause geht es nahtlos weiter im
programm ist das nicht anstrengend doch
unternehmen genauso nicht so harmlos und
nett hier und jetzt im kinsky hat der
kleinste wenn ich sagte gibt es gute
nacht geschichte sagt mir doch egal
der ganz normale wahnsinn für
schwiegervater sandro wäre dieses modell
nicht denkbar gewesen
es hat sich ja unter den sinn dass das
ich dass ich selber reichlich
mutterrolle
das sind
durch hinter heime und das sind sie das
wäre geschafft uns nicht nötig ist und
das hat sich natürlich schon stark und
er versteht dass jetzt sogar sehr gut
dass durch sie agieren unterstützung für
alle ins vater rafael ist der arbeitstag
noch nicht zu ende
er hat sitzung im s&p parteisekretariat
diskussion aus aktuellem anlass
teilzeitmodelle und vereinbarkeit
[Musik]
notwendig da das holz repower will
haltung von moritz märkte und sprechen
die körper diese personen sind ja
exportfirmen ist wovor sich selben zeit
endlich wird weniger scharfe oder es
also das brauwasser stigmatisiert wenn
es den hund verschafft
wenn du morgen gab es mit hält frau
immer wieder sagt bärbel schäfer bin ich
morgen mit kind und frau antwortet oder
schnell wachsen wie möglich zu prüfen
kathrin will in ihrer karriere schon
vorwärts kommen
vorerst ist aber raphael dran
waren mir der website teile und beide
werden teilte high und wann sie möglich
wäre mit 80 karriere machen wie mit 100
oder name haben
das ist im moment noch im museum der
druck auf unternehmen teilzeit karrieren
anzubieten jedenfalls wächst
entscheidend ist aber dass paare die
neuen chancen auch privat
gleichberechtigt verhandeln welches
modell sie wählen hängt davon ab welche
prioritäten sie dann setzen
patrick ist es wichtig früh nach hause
zu kommen dann ist er für die kinder da
war ja da gott dass ich gerade darum so
groß also ich habe das gefühl war es ein
vorteil ist konstein sind dass ich damit
regel jeder tag bezüglich regulierte
tagtäglich der ct das ist so sicher sich
natürlich auch recht gut vor dass ich
sie nicht machen ablösen aber dass sie
weiß ich bin da immer wieder muslime ja
wer ich wann und was man so schon
organisiert und ein großer vorteil finde
ich glaube ich dass mir sehr sehr
selbständig sind das wirklich eigentlich
jemand auch gewisse sind natürlich die
situation aber man froh ist dass ich
kriegen kann vielleicht das wochenende
aber mich wirklich alles sehen so viel
tolles machen wir jetzt gerne hätte der
gesichtsnerv andreas gibt dasselbe was
die flexibilität
barbara und mike nähmen in kauf dass ihr
leben ein bisschen chaotisch ist und
dass sie auf fremdbetreuung angewiesen
sind
dafür haben sie ihre rechte und
pflichten gleichmäßig verteilt wenn sie
das familienmodell geht was
dennis studenten paris account klar ist
der druck offenbar sehr groß so wenig
dass jetzt büßen modell als großer
vorteil dass es wirklich gut verteilt
ist steht den haltestellen verdacht
jeder glaube mal in jobs wackler und
vielleicht deshalb
der ist immer noch erst selbst vom
komisch nach wie vor einfach gesichert
also dass gegend wo sie entspannen
[Gelächter]
rafael ist auf dem heimweg
seine kinder hat er heute nicht gesehen
unter der woche zähne sind nicht so viel
das ist ja so gerne mit ihnen zusammen
ins bett bringen
es gibt wochen aber das schwierig ist am
wochenende eine mehrheitlich entführt
familie jetzt der letzten zweieinhalb
jahren ist geschafft nur zweimal am
wochenende die ferien versuche aber die
ihre schlimme hits machen zeit als paar
haben raphael und kathrin o am abend
speck das ist okay für den moment wo man
sich so verwurzelt dass ich das machen
das ist wirklich das gibt mir viel
es werden lebensabschnitte kommen in
denen anderes wichtig wird gut wenn man
dann gemeinsam wieder neue prioritäten
setzen kann
[Musik]